episode 127 six okay wait yeah 126 it
was last week the fall winter fashion
faux clothing colors yeah this is 126 um
so what do we got let's plug some stuff
away saturday san diego this saturday
the twenty-eighth i'm doing the tipsy
crow I'm gonna run my album there so
you're in san diego and you want to come
to that here in town if you're not out
of chanukah hollow if everything's doing
that's a 7pm it's mal hall show a funny
comic could do that he's been running
that thing for seven years great venue
great room the crowds are always good so
come see me do that and then he saw San
Francisco the middle of December 16
through 19 headlining the punch line i
am recording an album 18 and the 19 who
shows each night get tickets everybody
if you're in town i would love to see
you there for that and I think that's
and thank you for buying my pins you
guys are still buying them and I still
appreciate that if you haven't got one
get one they're gonna eventually sell
I'm going to take them up to San
Francisco with me so i'll sell them at
the shows
and i have a few copies of my first
album on vinyl left so i'm gonna bring
those up there i don't know how many
there are but i'm gonna bring them up
and sell those so you can get them there
but they'll eventually be gone and
they'll never be made again so please
buy one now and that's it
the punch language be in delray the 20th
planet of December so go to that party
you like stuck in your body weight
depending on which philosopher yes some
would say that exists outside I never
asked if Allah Springs they probably
just answer with a question only so
that's how we've gotten the answers to
everything we've ever known nope
Wikipedia is how we got together Oh news
is look it up in the Bible now also uh
Lake Tahoe 23 to 27 I'm playing to
improv there through Christmas so if
you're lonely and you're up there so
will I be lonely and up there that's
going to get weird in a way that I think
will be good it could I mean they're
dark on Christmas Eve so there's no
shows Christmas Eve but the other all
the other nights are our I'm sure a lot
of families and [ __ ] go up there yeah
you know it's like a winter destination
Benny how I'll be up there as well and
go to Nick Yousef Khan we're all all
shows ticket links to every show you can
buy my pin there to under merge and
everything else Instagram Twitter all up
soon and if you subscribe to the podcast
on iTunes thank you if you haven't do so
if you haven't rate rated it and
reviewed it do that that helps us so
click click however many stars you think
we deserve we're going to suggest five
and leave some kind of review you know
positive neutral negative whatever be
honest speak from your heart don't do
that don't speak from your heart okay um
alright let's do get into this episode
man one of our favorites the team
forties team came by you both talk
concerts we talk politics first among
the election
then we talked favorite concerts and
worst comes yeah we picked like two each
what do we like what do we don't like
yeah and it's just like a fun
conversation I music it's pretty
straightforward if you listen to jason
tiya on these podcasts before you kind
of know what you're what you're getting
he knows his music he loves his music as
a funny dude uh and it was a good
conversation man we always love having
him on I think he is now tied with Jerry
Ferrara for legacy guests yep I think he
is I'm gonna have to go back and count
or ease up by half or something doesn't
have like a half episode or whatever in
a half yeah god I should just ask him as
that account cuz he'll know I know he's
already looked it up yeah so there you
have it follow Jason on Twitter at the
TPA GT eeee his instagram is Jason Tebow
spell j-a-y som thi ba ult and then
obviously is one of the three hosts of
the punch drunk sports podcast on all
fours comedy would be him Sam Tripoli
and the dirty Jew he knows are so
subscribe to that listen to that those
guys are [ __ ] great as you probably
already know and that'll do it enjoy
this episode and happy thanksgiving
that's in a couple days so enjoy that
and we'll see you after you spend all
your money on
yo
yeah the difference between what gets
likes on like Twitter like post the same
thing I'm jitter and Facebook Twitter
will get like 37 favorites facebook it's
like one no it's the same internet a lot
of the same people maybe they'd even
follow you it's weird yeah I don't
understand that I don't think I've ever
I don't I think I've ever posted
anything on facebook gonna be good at
that sentence ended right there I don't
did I mean yeah I guess it did yeah I
think I've reposted a thing I don't
think of it yeah yeah I only puts them
on my comedy page I never use my regular
right for really I only have a regular
one yeah I just stopped using it a long
time ago just because it was on me I
don't know four thousand of my friends
they're just like when Facebook for
Chartres you were just except except
except you know like because you were
trying to copy what myspace was doing
sugar I gotta accept everybody and then
it just turns into people posting you
know rants about whatever [ __ ]
political issues in the news yeah and
then everyone gets racist and homophobic
and sexist and year and it just becomes
like a garbage dump of thoughts it's a
great place to find out your extended
family or racist or everybody that
you're friends with he because it's like
they can speak long-form yeah so they'll
post like a video link and then their
opinions on you know the Middle East or
like gay marriage or whatever and you're
like there's so many people and then
you're just like unsubscribing from your
newsfeed just over and over every one of
those pokes starts with I never do this
and you look like you actually do this
quarter yeah I take two people though I
you owe any time anyways like look man
I'm not racist but ok there this comes
I'm not political and I think like you
know war is wrong but we should bomb
everyone in the world you know I all
this things like everybody I posted
thing about because everyone so like you
know uh it's become such an agenda based
site and it's like everyone's like all
these Muslims when they're blaming all
Muslims and I'm like blaming all Muslims
and people like you know that follow
Islam and all that for all this
terrorism [ __ ] is like blaming the cake
that like Christianity for the KKK it's
easy it's the exact same thing
yeah you know and then it's [ __ ] so
stupid to just make these general
Blanque like man we should bomb
everybody that's like a sec you yeah its
exact same flat in that whole region
you're like all right it's like there's
a handful of like really really horrible
people my favorite question when anyone
brings up any Middle East thing like say
right now it's Syria so they'll start
talking about Syria and then I'll go
where's Syria on a map and then if they
can't answer that question I'm like
we're not talking anymore mm-hmm if you
don't even know and then somebody will
go like well that's irrelevant exact
where it is exactly it's like no it's
not regional conflicts are based on
where the [ __ ] the place is really
regional so if you don't even know what
countries it's next to and why
anything's happening how can you all of
a sudden decide it's an entire religions
fault yeah I mean it's andy but I'm like
within every religion there are [ __ ]
within every job there are [ __ ] in
every room there is an [ __ ] all right
till to walk into a room walk into a
party and there's three [ __ ] to be
like oh yeah exactly so why can't it be
like oh that [ __ ] here everybody
here is an [ __ ] its rapid you know I
mean we can all agree that the Quakers
are pieces of [ __ ] yeah of course man
Amish and black musician vote when can
we get sore women oh yeah horse women
shouldn't yeah well or men Quaker women
yeah Quaker women right it pretty much
is the three of us should vote all right
I didn't definitely not vote I hope
Trump kids to be President now I was I
was imagining that like as I was
watching a clip one of his speeches and
I was like there's a possibility there's
a world where he could be President is
like no chance in hell if the right for
no no not right now the with the way the
world currently is working right now not
not happening but you can like imagine
the right set of circumstances that
would lead him to getting electical fact
that we live in a day and age where
somebody like that can even be put into
the forefront of thought of the
possibility being president 30 40 years
ago he would have been laughs at he
would like no no there's no way there's
no way it was like social media and all
that money it's like he can make himself
prevalent
and and and and you know over saturate
everything that we look at in his name
pops up his laptop on the news he'd
already dropped out by now like this is
just the longest he's ever had to do
well they're also starting like the
debates earlier they're doing more of
him so he can actually last a little
longer because it's so early on he
doesn't really have to be spending any
money yet but once there's already four
or five candidates that have dropped out
and then soon he'll have to start you
know touring more and putting more money
in and then when he realizes it's not
going to happen then he'll have to drop
out I wonder gotta drop out yeah this I
mean he won't get the nomination
obviously but but it's funny when you
look back like people thought when
Reagan was running like an actor's
running for president that guy served
two terms when the second Bush was
running to like this idiot that with
barely any political experience the son
of no way he served two terms yeah I
think people have underestimated how
many or ok it's not votes yet it's poll
numbers how hide your how high your poll
numbers can get by just being like build
a wall and blow everything up people
like yep fine with me like there's a
large still a large contingent of the
country's like I like that yeah nice to
build a wall guy he's entertaining to
watch for like a bad guy in wrestling
and there's something very Roddy Piper
about him sure we're like you either
like totally like him because you are
also a [ __ ] total idiot and he speaks
your language you should build a wall
for those [ __ ] wetbacks yeah if
you're that dumb ass unit mean or or you
want him out so bad that you are just
watching him and seething it every word
that he says and rooting against him
yeah yeah i mean really good he's like a
really good politician in like the the
most the broadest sense of the term you
know i mean like he's loud he uses buzz
phrases like he's looking at what what
are all the major issues and i'm gonna
take the hardest furthest stance in my
party so like as far right as i can go
and just throw out these you know buzz
phrases and then have the people that
are supportive of that is super
confident yeah i need a lot of money and
he's got a lot of money that's all you
need to be proud
yeah he can easily last like another I
mean can you imagine even not even 50
years ago 20 years ago if a president if
if George Bush called Rosie O'Donnell a
fat pig yeah the hell he would have paid
yeah you would have been like oestrus
aww I would have been laughed out of the
office and this guy is like a hero for
tell you're uh you're an idiot you're
stupid it you know means acting like
yeah he would be accredited in calling
people fat pigs the kind of things you
would get bounced for he's done like 40
or 50 times yes day I was watching is
known for not only is he done at 40 50
yet I was watching I don't know some
show and and they were saying of the
Republican primary is so different this
time because you can basically do
whatever you want yeah and no one's
being like the kind of things that we
you would normally get in trouble for
there's just not you're not getting in
trouble for like Ben Carson saying the
pyramids were grain silos like the
Catholic all right well you're done it's
like no this did not even it does
there's not a blip it just like a trump
calling ben Carson it's saying you
similar to a child molester yeah week
ago like it just went away didn't yeah
nothing happened is it it it still
attracts like viewers in it engaging
people in a conversation so you can say
anything you want and it'll be in the
news the next day because they just need
to fill the content need content yes so
there's a ben Carson said and I'll talk
about that for a day until Trump says
something crazier and then someone else
tops that and then they'll keep going
but once it starts getting more serious
they'll you know they'll sideline those
people but don't drop out you know my
favorite thing is like the whole
immigration thing that he is just just
his platform yeah which I'm just like
everybody here is an immigrant yeah you
know I mean we're just 200 you know
years down of like this country is
founded on immigrants the only people
that should have a dog in the fight
against immigrants coming to america by
the American Indian yeah but they don't
really have much of a voice since we
murdered all of them right you know yeah
and he's like man it did immigrants
should just not be allowed to come to
America I'm like that's what America
is you dumb [ __ ] i know i'm not even
paying any attention to bail out of it
and I normally love it I normally love
election season I find it fascinating at
it it's all it's sort of just too it's
too frustrating to watch well it hasn't
really started yet yet because they're
doing a bunch of debates does it mean
like a pregame yeah this is like the
minor leagues you know not get rid of
all them and then they'll you know it's
it's got it's not a yes and it's just
entertainment right now I just hope
Bernie Sanders wins you won't hear on it
is no way well now I almost think you
drug has a better chance in standard he
does Sanders can't keep saying he's a
socialist it's not you can't you're not
gonna elect a socialist right it's too
bad Canadians can't vote in the American
election that'd be really funny yeah
like a sort of a vote were like they
like it they're the tiebreaker yeah
there's a tiebreaker all of Canada votes
and that counts for like a small person
yet their tiebreaker I would def that
seems like an excellent Bernie Sanders
would win them yes exactly I one
candidate about Canada and Mexico should
have like you know oh god Majesty Mexico
gotta vote withdraw apologies in Mexico
and Canada voted they probably cancel
each other out I know it pletely
convinced that someone that you know cuz
El Chapo put a 60 million dollar price
on Trump's head I'm not completely
convinced someone's not going to murder
him I'd kill I'd kill it's a lot of 60
million I swear on my life I would kill
him for six million oh that's so
question i'll say that into a podcast
you really he dies if he dies lookbook
for me ask me where I was interrogate me
if he gets murdered if you cuz if you
killed him and immediately it's I'm just
saying it's very dangerous to him to
campaign in California because we're
close enough to the Mexican border to
where if you killed him and got to
Mexico that day and we're like I did it
a lot of people will be willing to hide
you Mexico Texas lose like a few states
yeah it would be close enough close
enough Arizona New Mexico I mean it
could kind of just cruise around me like
I don't know one who did it and they'd
be like huh welcome to our home enjoy
our basement right and you just have to
pave you'll off here's ten grand here's
the grand I have 60 million dollars
coming in he would be fun to torture
yeah you would be you know i mean just
have a min a chair like a like why
picture like one of those basements was
just like one swinging light bulb and
headed up to a chair instead of like
loud music you would just like use hair
clippers you just turn those on and then
getting closer and closer with them yeah
yeah yeah yeah you start torture him
with just logic cut parts of his hair
away make him say stupid did like things
in the videos like cameras like how he
loves Mexicans and all the stuff is
slowly release those tapes I wonder if
you could be like you can be President
if you shave your head like if like that
would be like that's the bag of bets for
him like yeah go like it like shave your
head let us see your real head and we by
the way you get it tomorrow you start
tomorrow let us see your real head he
would do it you think yeah I think
anybody would doesn't he realize that
that hair is one of the biggest things
holding him back as it makes I think
it's more his mouth and the things that
come out of it it's all to me together
like that it makes him look so
inherently silly in like you you saying
you tell it like it is with that thing
on your excellent II did this is real
though like I feel like every time I see
him on the news but doesn't it seem like
you know like he's an aisle on is 4,000
people at some rally and he's yapping
about you know get Mexicans out of my
country and all this [ __ ] i watch it
i'm like 'i people can think this is
real it doesn't know that doesn't these
people to hear his issues are they there
to go like I saw Donald Trump I get
worried that we're gonna be like this
this it's this is [ __ ] right up
until it's not do you mean like yeah
worries me that like the debt has been
in it longer than he ever has he's done
he's doing better than he ever has but
that's not how like that he still would
have to get in like the party nomination
yeah I need a very hard the thing that
he hasn't done he hasn't gone through
actual part the one thing I doubt he has
is uh actual primary apparatus like the
actual pain but thing is he has a ton of
money to hire those people but a lot of
that stuff is sewn up kind of early like
precinct captains and things like that
but I just I wonder he's done you know
every time they're like yeah i mean i
can't tell you to put even to three
months ago they're like yeah he's on the
it's waning like you
I would see Stefan like having opposed
all timely Trump's it's going away and
then it just doesn't but when you look
at it like day to day and you keep
reading all these things it becomes more
real but let us three months is a long
time and that's like a long time for
other candidates to drop out and others
to gain traction and steam and then have
more of the party backing them you just
see more of them and less of Trump and
then they'll eventually just get
sidelined like a month ago people were
like listening all the you know things
Ted Cruz and all these other guys were
saying no like I can't believe this
guy's running you're like it's the first
debate and we're like you know a year
and however out from from the camp from
the actual general election it's like
don't pay attention to it I feel like
the people that go to see trumpet like
these like you know these like rallies
or whatever you go in there's like an
four or five thousand people I feel like
they did go for the same reason that
like people went to go see Charlie Sheen
do stand-up after he lost his mind yeah
they're not there for the content
they're there to say I went I saw this
lunatic back and I was there well yeah
there it's he's like a reality star as
far if like literally is yeah there's
like Hillary Clinton would be a real
politician and Donald Trump is like the
reality star version there's no other
candidate where you're going to go or
very few ben Carson says wacky stuff but
you're not going to go to most of the
other candidates rallies and hope to see
something ridiculous come out of their
mouth with him you're like no I could
take the empty I could say I was at the
trump rally where he finally dropped the
n-bomb hahahaha like ya know I was there
it was [ __ ] nuts dude yeah he did it
it's gonna happen you got or somebody's
gonna get him saying some [ __ ] like
secretly record him saying some stuff
when it gets a little closer like
someone's gonna wear a wire so they
already have that now have you were off
it I think it money worth it would be it
would be out because it's worth 10
million dollars hearing him say like all
these stupid [ __ ] or something like
that I got it you had a really
incriminating thing on him you were so
much money yeah senia then you're in
like a negotiation between Trump how
much is this worth to you because here
is how much TMZ is gonna pay
gotten better at being careful is even
if even the way he reacted to the Paris
attacks you're like oh you're being more
careful he's just being more careful
he's gotten better at it yeah either his
about his new advisors or he hasn't /
advisors that are like if you want this
to actually go any further you start
paying attention and being a little more
selective with your word what do you
thinks it happened with like concert
security in American after these attacks
now because in Europe it's like they're
stepping it up everywhere to get there
earlier well I'll tell you what I'm
never gonna go see Queens donate as for
sure Eagles death are Eagles that show
us yeah either one of them in any any
any other any of those bands uh I think
it'll be getting there I think you're
gonna have to get their way earlier
they'll be like there and take off your
shoes and jacket yeah and it's gonna be
like it's gonna be a thing like big
jackets and you're gonna like you kind
of think like I don't want to wear like
something that'll make me get searched
longer I'm just going in a bikini yeah
that's it I think this takes a lot of
heat off of like who cares if you have a
joint yeah anatomy and ukulele security
are here hold this joint while I [ __ ]
prove their innate or whatever uh yeah I
mean it wouldn't be hard to like ramp
ups like all the venues are owned by
like three companies anyway so all they
have to do is like okay hire 50 thousand
more security guards yeah and then Pat
everyone down a little longer I I think
security guards gonna be being like an
uber driver recon Oh ever it's me like a
cater waiter we can just get work doing
see our teacher probably yeah probably I
tell you what I wouldn't want to go
through is the security I would not want
a super bowl ticket oh well yeah not
because I'm afraid of a bomb going off
because I don't want it to take me three
and a half hours to get to my seat yeah
you know well I was a terrorist that and
I wanted to make a statement in America
like you know a big [ __ ] thing like
that Super Bowl or Academy Awards yeah
right because everybody's watching yeah
you know if you wanna strike fear into
you know like American men
in a children all that bomb Super Bowl
if you want to terrify gay men and women
bomb the [ __ ] Academy Award do both of
them in you got us crippled in fear yeah
all right you know or I mean imagine
going you you got tickets to sporting
event and didn't realize it like it was
one of the ones like the president
decided to go to you and you wouldn't
even get you probably get there like
it's gonna be a while you get in by like
the second quarter because it would just
take that much longer that's what the
the guys who went to the stadium they
were you know trying to get in the
president was there that was the big
goal so anything like that where there's
just anything extra fancy about a event
there it's going to be like when you buy
your ticket I bet you you know you buy
tickets online you're gonna get an email
like allow this much time yeah get there
the Super Bowl Sunday dinner Friday
night yeah time you would normally
tailgate show up naked with your hands
in the air yeah here's what you
shouldn't bring like don't like unless
you need a backpack like for real don't
bring it and prices will go up more
about you imagine paying three grand for
a Super Bowl ticket which is probably
1,500 23 grand is probably the good it
goes for and you know they don't even
have that many tickets because they they
give so many away and so many go to so
many things really uh-huh but imagine if
you had like fifteen hundred bucks or
three thousand dollars for a Super Bowl
you get to go to the Super Bowl which i
think is in San Francisco this year and
you miss ten minutes of the game because
you're [ __ ] with security yeah do you
imagine how mad you would be you'd be
really bad I be like uh yeah you owe me
eight hundred dollars hey NFL I get
there I mean I camp out overnight and
just being the first in line yeah
exactly I'm not missing a simple tickets
I'd go there super early anyways just
like walk around I love walking around
stadiums me too like if I have Dodger
tickets and I can get there really early
i like getting there really really early
just like cruising around the stadium
been to a lot of stadiums know uh I've
been uh what we need it all sport I mean
not just football but at all no I've
never been to a football game really
I've no I've been to a UC like I've
never been to a professional bugging
I've been to Dodger Stadium Wrigley the
White Sox Wrigley the best yeah you
gotta remember we're from here and we
haven't had a football team in which one
years yeah yeah but I did you a lot of
like just around just different cities
you know if I'm in that town and there's
a game like I'm a [ __ ] a game
Detroit yeah I've never seen an NFL game
when I think about a scene NBA and major
league baseball games live yeah and
those are fun yeah I'd love to go to a
football game blast i loved pirate
stadium a place was cool yeah and I when
I worry rivers yeah the Pirates were so
bad I went and I had per diem because
working there and I was like I'm gonna
get rad seats like you got to early
enough they like a you're gonna be
starting pitching today yeah I was like
AG one on the field like right up
against their ex wheat 25 bucks like it
was not an an in-demand ticket there's
barely any way the gang I just moved
around the stadium to be in the shade
did you like Wrigley Field aw dude it's
that net I said really close now that
thing is bigger net hley there's that
part like I had fields like right of the
field and I but I was just past the net
I was like um a foul ball could
legitimately kill me uh-huh those
seasoned fries though delicious yeah
Wrigley all the freaky is gunning I want
a government now it's the best it's so
cool because you're just walking around
like a really nice gentrified
neighborhood and then you take a right
turn you're like oh wow there's yeah
baseball stadium in the middle of this
neighborhood feel smaller of buy it once
I've been to a couple games they call it
the world's biggest singles bar yeah
that's fine and like I've been to many I
mean I probably anymore cuz games than
any other any other like teams thing
just cuz i grew up in that area we're in
a happiness so i am very upset there is
many a times i have left that stadium
hammered is [ __ ] and another surprise
both of you but no clue who won the game
like me and my buddies would be in a bar
like what did we win or did we lose and
I've also been to a bar harry caray's
has a bar right across the street and it
used to be really really popular when he
was alive it wasn't as touristy as it's
become even though it was still touristy
and walking into that bar where
everybody in the bar is chanting we're
number four
house not seriously that team it's like
literally we're here to get drunk
there's a baseball game that is also
going on yeah but it's not the priority
Chicago's the best really owes on that
and of that place it's so fun Wrigley
feels great I saw the arcade fire in
Chicago last year oh yeah you and re
yeah right where's that at what a dinner
that what is it united center united
center yeah yeah where the bulls and
blackhawks yeah yeah which is a cool
cool arena but that was one where we got
there early to we walked around I saw
Blackhawks games me too the national
anthem at Blackhawks games is pretty
spectacular one stands and you applaud
the whole time and and didn't you cheer
your ass off and they usually get like
an army like a military style singer to
do it it's very aggressive in patriotic
after what you're like hand me a gun
let's go do this that United's and it's
like it's kind of like the staple center
in a way I mean it's very modern and new
and it's smaller I feel it but it used
to be like right across the street was
Chicago Stadium which was very for a
mask okay where it's like it's just a
big circle and you feel like you're more
in a gym then at a you know like a
modern sort of thing wrecking ball bat
and then built the united states united
center is nice i like in there we we
like we got there really early before
anything starting we just kind of walked
around the entire place and it was cool
it was one of those arenas that that
sits a little lower so it doesn't feel
like like the forum it's a cavernous it
feels like yeah you know like I villains
gonna hide like a spaceship there you
know yeah yeah yeah this secretly store
it you know um but uh but i liked United
Center it was cool and arcade fire was
great they use the the entire floor you
know it was one of those shows where
they performed end stage but they had a
stage in the middle that they would use
to like appear out of so they go
underneath and then like come out in the
middle and they'd have like you know
people dancing or whatever and so Arcade
Fire's the male and female singers yeah
and there's a couple songs where they
kind of sing to each other and then the
guy win was on one side and then Regina
was on the other and they were like
singing at each other
and you're like in the middle like
looking you know back and forth it was
really well done the way they did it was
awesome a buddy of mine was going to
school in michigan is a long time ago
not super long time ago but and arcade
fire just like they're like first album
had anyone come out yet uh you know man
they were touring and they did his like
little like art school in michigan and
they played the psych town and is like
he liked it i was like maybe thousand
people with this thing yeah and then he
was hanging out with them and there's
not many people are in 30 people in
arcade fire exactly and they were like
in the midst of figuring out what hotel
they were going to all stay at yeah and
they couldn't and my buddies like you
can come stay back at our dorm I know
like really they're like yeah and all of
them were like in different rooms it's
like sleeping with different you know
everybody had like one person in the
band on their dorm floor that's holy and
there really are like eight or nine of
them but a lot of people have been two
years later they're like super you know
their first album came out and it was
like they hit the ground running with
that [ __ ] one of my shows for favorite
was that was in the running for favor
one what is a show I went to in Chicago
which was strokes at the Metro where's
the met what's the metro a small venue
it's probably the size of the palace
yeah yeah me i was called now the palace
or we saw where we saw little bit uh no
no II saw Jake bugg smaller than that it
Metro smoke metros like kind of like
maybe like I'm fonda sized or or yeah
that one is where we subject but yeah I
said palladium palladium okay the fights
about the size of the fonda or music box
now I guess uh I think it's both is it
yeah well yeah it's always fond at the
music box although is called they have
like both sigh I don't know what they're
doing with that place yeah like as far
as names go but yet that it was the the
record had just the first record had
just come out and uh so there were in
Chicago's a very serious music city very
bit was almost like everyone was there
to see what the big deal was but there
was a lot of young kids they're like
teenage like 1789 isn't strokes just
canna first album just for someone that
pipe was like Rios my favorite album of
theirs yeah
the hype was ridiculous like every you
know they're on the cover of Rolling
Stone every music magazine was freaking
I was like the return of rock that was
kind of their their their their the
boulder on their shoulder was that yeah
yeah yeah rock is Punky cool again now
that was just like New York rock they're
calling a rebel rock it was back and the
Moldy Peaches opened they were horrible
yeah they were like infuriating but then
the strokes came out why were they
infuriating like songs were just like
annoying and cute and then like their
banter in between was annoying like hey
you guys want to go somewhere and [ __ ]
in some condoms you like okay yeah he
just wasn't good crappy what a visual
yeah like oh my god you guys are so
weird but this sucks and then strokes
took a really long time to come out but
then they did and they've just blew the
doors off the place and that's a cool
small venue yeah and it was like
everything you know the out because they
all they did was play the albumen order
and then leave the stage but it was like
there's like steam coming off of the
crowd and I'm at one point they go they
play last night and during the guitar
solo someone throws a cubs hat onstage
and Albert Hammond catches it in midair
just puts it on his head and then
everyone started like stabbing it yeah
I'm so happy I what else to do the roof
ugly open like a [ __ ] they throw that
he catches it puts it on his head right
before he plays the guitar solo and last
night and I mean teenagers were fainting
yeah that was like the first night of
like recorded cases of spontaneous human
we were just caught fire and blew up it
was one of those moments where I was a
little I was a lot older than I think I
was probably 25 or something and you
were ten years older than everybody in
the gap and I remember looking at the
crowd and being and you could see kids
deciding to grow their hair longer and
wear tighter jeans you know and it was
just like you first of all suffer I
realized watch them was like oh it's
it's rock and roll you can dance to and
talk to girls around yeah yeah like more
importantly rock and roll girls can
danced yeah and we were also dancing now
you know you can sidle up yeah exactly
which in up until the point there wasn't
that and so out it was fun you read
something that was felt fun with it they
just destroyed that place and I'm wet my
friend James who was you know he liked
them we both liked them but i like them
way more he was like an again he was
like that was [ __ ] crazy it was so
good it was just [ __ ] great it was
like a rock and roll you felt like it
was like the 70 cuz I mean at my age I'm
I feel like I missed out on a lot of big
musical movements but I was like this is
what we want you know like the late
seventies punk scene oh you back for
more like legitimate punk when it was
happened the things when they were
happening right yeah and so I was like
you know I'm sure this wasn't as crazy
as seeing like the velvet underground
but this was pretty close to being is
this was great you know felt like like
it was happening at that moment they
just came out it was a new band and
everyone was [ __ ] excited yeah it
might not even feel great now though but
like in another 15-20 years you're gonna
be talking to some kid who's going to be
like you saw the strokes before their
first album came out and that to that
kid will feel like how you would feel
about some velvet underground story by
someone who's 50 right now yeah yeah
yeahs yet told it takes a while for it
to register as like a cultural shift you
know because like people who saw
Nirvana's unplugged it wasn't really
probably cool even in 97 98 99 but like
right now it's becoming one of those
things were like I'm like [ __ ] man i
wish i was at that no [ __ ] you know and
in another 15 years you're like that's
one of those rare concert experiences
you hear about those shows in sacramento
worked the guys like my first show ever
went to was a op ivy black religion
Black Flag you're like which is like
crazy right back up yeah if you heard
that story in 1997 you would have been
like cool show yeah but now you're like
you did what [ __ ] give me your eyeballs
and your brain I know I know
eat them we would be like I can you
believe that all to collectively was it
out yeah how did they even autonomously
that's a gate was in a gym you're like
dude seriously yeah yeah that's why i
use venues make a show now you know you
can see a great band at like you know at
like uh but what's a [ __ ] place in
pasadena the Rose Bowl yeah I'd be like
it was cool but Jesus a hundred thousand
people everybody looked this big yeah I
feel that way about the Hollywood ball
like if it's Hollywood Bowl and I'm like
way the [ __ ] back and like almost by the
woods I'm like I can hear people talking
as much as I can hear the thing
everybody's this big right you know
that's why I like the Greek Theatre
better than the ball because that out
all day yeah absolutely and you know
what else is good is the Ford I've been
there really that's a from the first
place in LA I saw Wilco I don't know I
saw back at the Ford that's cool it was
true it was during the day was a k-rock
contest thing he [ __ ] destroyed it
was a hundred degrees he wore a silver
jumpsuit and just lit the place on fire
it was so good I saw back at UM the red
lion in silverlake yeah [ __ ] wow just
like he was just pluck nicked with fur
like there was a rumor that he was going
there all the time and just playing he
said you that way early early this is
2002 you know there's a lot maybe even
little after that a long time ago though
10 years ago easily 10 years ago and I
should go there all the time and and but
I man you just missed last night and
like I [ __ ] missed it again and in
one night there it is and he's just
sitting there like i like i like a one
of those shitty piano players in the
corner you know like I mean there was
less than 40 people in the room that's
insane and he was just like playing
piano and just singing didn't play
guitar didn't have it the only nose
plugged in was the mic that's insane and
you're like holy [ __ ] and then it then
it got cool to kind of just like not be
all about back and you just sitting
there drinking and hanging with your
friends and like not even really yeah
just like a man that's the guy playing
music for us it just happens to be back
it's funny we were Tom out like uh
coming up with like two of our favorites
into Harley's favor like I've had a hell
of a time doing it I can't come up with
tooth of like to I hated me I think I
know I come one that I hated I know one
for sure yeah i mean i know one that i
didn't like but it wasn't it was only
for one reason that i built into this
huge thing like but it wasn't something
like nothing terrible happened or like
the band was so awful or they walked off
stage or you know I've never had one of
those uh I saw a band that was so bad
and I literally they're really catchy
papi I didn't go to see them because it
was one of those like um like a rock
acoustic Christmas one of those kind of
things and it was like when you go to
those uh at anybody listening to doesn't
that isn't familiar with Los Angeles
area they would always put these big
shows on like right before Christmas and
it would be like eight good bands you
know to me and you know you usually
would go there like oh I really want to
see and at that point in time it was my
interest in this what got my money was
this is my first time seeing the shins
and it was their second album and I've
never seen the shins and I'm absolutely
loved even to this day i saw i love all
their all of their their whole
discography but their first two albums i
love ya and those are two albums it like
earmark things in my life sure i can
listen to those two albums and and I'm
like time war I know what apartment i'm
in i know what girlfriend i have i know
what car I'm driving I know everything
you know I got a few i probably have my
actual comedy set list down from those
times in my life so I went there to see
that and one of the other bands that was
performing there is the arguably worse
band I've ever seen live third eye blind
dude my worst show to know why Campbell
even to this day if one of their songs
pops on yeah and even if it was a song
like back in the day I was like oh yeah
this is a happy-go-lucky sonnets unlike
change it these guys suck so much [ __ ]
yep I was blown away at how awful they
were mine
I happened they just he didn't sing and
not at all i was just gonna say they
don't sound anything like that live yeah
oh I thought of one that I don't like
they don't sell you said that anything
like that live okay they sound like and
then it just makes me go like who
produces album I do so whoever loses
album is a goddamn genius and can make
anybody sound good yeah they sounded
horrible yeah and that was an album
their first album I don't even know if
they have a second album they've
released the but they released one this
year is that true awful their first
album there was probably four or five
tracks on there that we're like yeah
yeah I'm like ah man that's not bad
absolutely awful and by the third song
I'm looking at my buddy I'm like is this
a michael am I having a stroke right now
or are you know is this the worst [ __ ]
you've ever heard Wow by the fourth song
people are booing ya know when they just
scrap it on the fifth song yeah wow I
did he look like he was like [ __ ] up
no no not at all he just is bad and I'm
talking about their missing chords I'm
telling what the guys can't play that
good drummer was really good the band
when I saw where'd you see him each six
open format the universal amphitheater
uh-huh so I went to that show that's
where I was to universal empathy that's
where they had the Christmas correct
yeah so this was just a dedicated each
six eighty dollars a beer as well and
that's another reason I was pissed of
setting right so I went to go see you
six played a huge venues I think that
with did that point was like the biggest
venue they played and it was you know
for us it was like the craziest because
everyone a lot of people actually showed
up for to see 62 so it was full while
they were playing which for an opener is
pretty rare and so we were like blow it
was like the coolest we're all freaking
out third eye blind comes up were like
okay cool he he just couldn't hold a
note we need to what like his voice was
cracking sounded like was off yeah
that's day I'm listening to ke rock and
the DJ whoever was the time was like she
had the fish something I was Jed the
fish it was someone else younger he goes
yeah what's that you six third eye blind
show last night e six was great that the
guy from third eye blind needs to take a
singing lesson really busted him on the
area was like he was whole
that's so funny that our first ones are
the same gitam it speech impediment like
Josh Martin singing yeah it really is it
really is it is our next song yeah it's
just like and he couldn't holy couldn't
hit or hold any notes the songs just
sounded did you sounded legitimately bad
I've never heard that like you think I
mean cuz they've toured you think like
that would be a widely known thing like
oh whatever heard anybody say I saw them
and they were good I've never heard
anyone say I saw that's true so long
right right i think they would have
built a reputation for cuz a certain
artists that have reputations for being
like really unpredictable live a really
bad or like moody hat power cat Power's
one uh the black lips route used to be
known for being like insane and they
would like get kicked out of any is like
[ __ ] on fire like bands develop
reputations you think they would a dozen
roses in notorious for something like
[ __ ] later or distinct [ __ ] you right
here that song how's it going to be the
third eye blind one yeah when he gets
the part where he's like would you don't
know me and can't hold he's like but you
know ever like it's just not even words
dude is awful you're and when I wanna go
to youtube there live maybe he got
better I whatever but like dude it was
bad Wow I mean it was bad and I was
gonna like men is going to be a good you
know like I wish I could remember who
was all on that show but it was um it
was them it was who's the like uh uh
then it would vanish guitar playing guy
and girl Santana oh no rodrigo y
gabriela yep and that's what I never
even heard of them though they're
unbelievable amazing yeah that was like
they're coming out party they were like
the first you know they like oats opened
it up like no one had even heard of them
really I saw them [ __ ] at Coachella
like they slowly blew up each year each
year I've always in my mind been like I
mean good for them because they were
awesome when I saw the first year
there's like a big like the a big buzz
they were playing at Coachella and ice
because it's just a guy in a girl on
guitar there's no lyrics they're just
instrumental but oh wow man haha vanish
guitar yeah like an erotic to cover like
a king floyd songs like unbelievable you
gotta do
sexy great yeah so I was sitting side
stage on the stage like five like what
for the listener care but like as far as
we you and I are sitting with other
right now 62 part yeah and there and you
can just see how close you know like I'm
you're sitting so close sorry that like
them playing these guitars and you're
just like you get transfixed on immune
is like how are they [ __ ] did use
easily like to have 10 fingers on each a
replicated Spanish guitar players are
wizards yeah okay see someone ripping a
Spanish guitar like whoa dude relax yeah
let alone two of them yeah you know in
that coordinated [ __ ] you're like all
right you win yeah they're of yet you
win he has the baby they're getting like
huge reactions from from the crowd and
they weren't even saying award which is
how impressive the guitar food
instrumental it always like takes a
minute when sharp you're like other
really singing after a while if they're
good people like all right this is the
[ __ ] yeah because you're like you people
just shred so hard yeah and a good like
that's how I mean that's how rare it is
for like there to be like an
exceptionally good uh musician onstage
with most bands because like there's a
lot of times like the band is just like
the band but certain bands have like a
standout person who's kind of just as
famous you know yeah yeah band itself or
about uh and know like they'll stand out
or like they'll be like the most famous
person because of how good they are at
that instrument they're not even the
lead singer something like right you
know I mean like when I was like that
what it you know John Frusciante is the
one please also you know considered a
great bass player in his personality is
more why he's yeah I waxing John
Frusciante doesn't ever say a word yeah
but he is like the reason you go see the
Chili Peppers yeah like he's such an
amazing guitarist yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah he put out this [ __ ] album
without a ton of solo albums and just
recently he said he's he's not going to
anymore cuz he's like no one buys him on
to the point it's just like I don't know
it's make all this work and no one
really like notices it or whatever but
he put out an instrumental only album
with the guitarist of the mars volta is
now an anti mask with the singer of the
result so they and he's a great
guitarist 20 more so they put out this
album
just instrumental seven tracks and it's
[ __ ] mind blowing it's sellable it's
so cool did and it's impossible to find
it's not on iTunes it's not on Spotify I
do really really hunt for it that and
the way I discovered it was I went to a
record store and I'm walking around
looking for like you know whatever and I
talked to the guy let you have any like
rare you know tool mooresville two
things you can't find and he goes no but
I have that any points in like what I
didn't hadn't even if it's on the wall
you're [ __ ] yeah yeah that's the rule
record shows yeah there's that thing in
that frame it has a padlock on it yeah
damn it yeah this is security guard
guarding it with a gun in the rottweiler
like one of those English guards with
the hats egestas never talk is just like
lasers crisscrossing the whole thing
yeah yeah like so is that expensive you
gotta rub down down and get it you have
to turn a key with him at the same so
anyway I was a rare yeah yeah so like
what the hell even is that is like Oh
John Frusciante and Omar for the mars
volta made it is wet on max yeah oh boy
so it's like this was it was the second
there were two pressings very limited
run it's next to impossible to find so
I'm like well what I mean can I find it
online as a good luck it's not on iTunes
you can't buy it anywhere and he's like
it's 50 bucks and I promise you you will
love it he's like I have a copy and I
listen to it all the time is like I'm I
promise you you'll love it I'm like you
know what I'd never spent that much
money on a record and I was like to date
that's most money you spend on a record
the podcast didn't end he's thinking no
because I'm normal about inside doing
I'm subtracting the amount of because i
had like gift cards for add amoeba and I
bought a record that was worth more but
with the gift cards it brought it way
down so trendy the math I got you but
it's probably maybe the second most but
there was another record the second mars
volta album it was a first pressing an
original that went for a hundred and ten
others and the but I had all these gift
card so i put it down to dropped it to
like probably 70 or so but it's like
online it's worth twice as much so it's
like i buy it and then it died tomorrow
I could sell it and make my money back
to to fold you know so same with that
one I was like well it's 50 bucks and
I'm like if it's that rare and I bought
it and then all of all the ones online
or worth way more on a white sold it for
that little may be dissin no no but
point being it was like this [ __ ]
it's an amazing I listen all the time
it's so [ __ ] good um but yeah guys
like that live when you see those dudes
like sometimes you go to a concert BTW i
like the band but i want to see what
this drummer this guitarist alive you
know because they could like God nels
cline the the wilco guitarist favor drum
I did favorite one of my favorite guitar
players yeah and him how he got in that
band where he was just like where work
quit music and was working on work at a
bank yeah he's like I'm done and then
they need a new guitarist and they're
auditioning people on the like oh this
guy's amazing yep next thing you know he
puts in his two weeks at the bank and I
was touring with a [ __ ] awesome rock
and roll yeah yeah no [ __ ] unreal my
favorite part about tool shows is when
the openers done and they're setting up
uh tool stuff when they unveil the not
like an unveiling like its name but
they're just setting [ __ ] up and they
take the tarp off the drum kit that gets
an applause break haha that's so badass
that's like that's how good a guy can be
at an instrument that no one that this
news is shading live instruments yeah
they just like and the guys aren't
paying a tender just like all right make
sure that's plugged in I'll just take
this nothing off the drum kit they just
wanna and nothing's even having it the
lights don't even understand remember
the drop yeah they just associate cuz
they're like I can't wait to watch Danny
Carey drum yeah that just seeing the
drum kit there like a it still not
happen were saying about I nels cline
uh-oh he's another guy where you're like
it like impossible germany sounds so
good on the album mm-hmm that you're
like I can't wait to just see feel this
live to me
that Howie that impressed a deal breaker
for me it's like if something so and I
tell you what and that's that's why I
really I walked away from that one
concert with two things 1i couldn't
believe how bad third eye blind was i
didn't go there to see them but I wasn't
upset that they were on the venue
because I'm like man if they're coming
out and what you know those kind of
super shows everyone does like eight
songs ten songs and in the headliner
I'll do you know 12 to 15 or whatever
whoever the you know the big [ __ ]
headliner is and I walked away from that
like these guys sounded so terrible and
all it really was was like poppy music
but I went to see the shin specifically
because I'm like they have he has such a
unique voice and they have such a unique
kind of sound yeah but I'm like I don't
know how they can replicate this live
and they sound exactly like that live
like they sound incredible live that's
funny I saw him once in San Diego and
they say rocked out more than they do on
the albums yeah which I like though cuz
i'm not a huge shins guy mmm and mad
maybe i missed the boat I just didn't
like jump on honey that's one of the
song oh yeah no no that's a modest mouse
on oh yeah that's true but he does
things on it so I saw him live and I was
like it was a rock festival and I was
like oh this might be like a you know
Babu's array and then I was like these
guys [ __ ] are killing it right now
yeah yeah yeah I got me a little bit
more at home yeah they probably had to
to their product man we can't do our
[ __ ] like yeah slower [ __ ] here at a
date like a date I'm music yeah yeah um
but one of my worst ones was uh in San
Diego might have been the same year at
that festival The Killers couldn't have
been a bigger band couldn't have been I
saw them and I didn't think they were
bad when I saw him I saw them what year
did you see him oh [ __ ] 2008 nine I
might've seen maybe a year before two
years somewhere around there but they
were playing the street scene in San
Diego which is now defunct vessel uh and
they were it was during that Sam's Town
album I think so the stage show just got
crazy huge and all the stuff
and uh everyone's excited and their
first album had like ten songs in nine
of them were in hit that you know is one
of those so I'm like this gonna be cool
and then they had all this like crazy
theatrical [ __ ] but like Brandon Flowers
as a live performer was so [ __ ]
boring that it like halfway through the
said I was like Matt that's a
good-looking do it yeah but it's like do
something he stood there like he was a
cardboard cutout of really flowers
that's crazy I like move around do
something sing a little I I mean maybe
it was an off night but a couple years
later I saman another festival and they
were better but like not by a lot really
yeah which annoys me it's like you're
gonna go watch a band it's like have a
live show is that the worst that you've
like paid to go see and you're kind of
like man that's [ __ ] sucked yeah I
don't I mean I can't think of a concert
that I've like gone to where I was like
[ __ ] these guys they [ __ ] her so bad
I want my money back or I'll never see
them again I I don't have any of those
mm-hmm that I can even like think of one
of the shows like I mean it was a bummer
was a bill to spill show oh no one
because he was sick and it was an all
cover show and there were covers I
barely knew but I covers of whatever you
want to cover it was just covered yet
songs I'd never heard he was like this
is by this person father's don't get
obscure and why and that defeats all
purpose of a cover the right everyone
was sort of bummed but they turned it
around cuz they close with free bird
full version whoo and it we were like
okay but up until that point it was not
a very good show but he was also sick
right and he was like I'm sorry this
next one is a Willie Nelson B side
you're like okay yet take place up there
but then this part is I would be all
over so yeah they started doing free
bird and after two minutes we were like
oh [ __ ] are you gonna do is this
happening and they did the full thing
and by the end everyone was the house of
blues and everyone was on their feet but
it was not a good show that's pretty
cool and I love that band so much my
second worst one is sad because I've
seen this person before really do well
and a big fan but I saw Elliott Smith
his last show at the fonda and was dead
two days later yeah he was so me and
Duncan Trussell yeah imma buddy Jay and
he was so [ __ ] up that he did songs
that he did two songs ago whoa dude he
would start songs and stop in the middle
and start like mumbling he would forget
lyrics and he at least three times he
started songs over like he would get
like a third of the way into the song
and then I [ __ ] [ __ ] it I [ __ ] always
forget it uh [ __ ] I'm just gonna start
over and then he would start the song
over and he just SAT kind of slumped
over in a chair with a guitar the whole
time Wow and probably did I don't know
50 minutes but like only three songs
probably six that's why he talked as
much as he sang do that as a stand here
like I run this bid oh wait two minutes
in absolutely [ __ ] up on I assume
heroin he wasn't like you know on coke
or meth or zinging you know he wasn't
[ __ ] Canada he would have done like
37 songs at 50 minutes absolutely i
ended up on the crowd all right now you
know that's that was the third time I'd
seen him in my life and in every time I
saw him just loved him and this time you
like a man this he ain't doing good you
know you didn't II was about to stab
himself in the heart with a knife but
you thought this guy's about to go to
rehab or this guy's about to overdose or
something like that sucks another one I
i saw that i hated but i didn't even
stay because i knew i was going to hate
it was at a festival so all i did was
walk like 50 yards and I'm in another
stage but it was MGMT when they released
her second album and they were all like
into [ __ ] drugs now the [ __ ] you know
and the first I was good lottery sounds
real
yeah totally the second one they were
all like we're in a [ __ ] heroin there
or whatever and I'm like oh this is
gonna [ __ ] suck so it comes out it's
not that great but I'm like I'm
something to watch him so I go over
there and there a few minutes late to
get started and then how like mumbling
and then he goes like so anyone out
there [ __ ] up on drugs oh my god like
see you later oh man says that just be
[ __ ] up on drugs yeah and then play
Jesus cry and I was like I'm not here I
the only thing I would have absolutely
have left but the only thing I would
have done different than you is boo the
whole way out right what was so far in
the back it wasn't it done it's just
it's not even about them hearing it it's
just about from my inside so i know that
i Bude them 15 it's like a 15 year old
drunk for the first time totally right
Oh messed up right right there yeah
that's exactly what that is that's
really funny so lame um best show
Radiohead at the Greek I knew one of you
[ __ ] was gonna say Radiohead man your
head I feel it's one of the Bears I've
never seen them Jhene record wait
thousand why I've never seen Radiohead
I'm saying that live in to your podcast
oh man I feel very bad about it I
thought what cuff I have never seen
radiated the only the closest I've ever
been to seeing Radiohead was when they
did in like two thousand they did um the
Hollywood Bowl I was in the woods that's
really funny that's the closest I've
ever been and about five six songs in
he's like um this songs for everybody
that's hiding up into the trees yeah and
then you hear this like ah like there's
like three thousand it's not like you
know like a like a war cry like wat
wildlings yeah it was just me and my
buddy Brian Jarvis is sitting up there
in the woods like not above the Greek
though is there woods above the bowl
yeah yeah this was about that absolutely
i mean i know there's woods that no they
were like ones cuz i've done that about
I I listen to James Brown above the
Greek once oh yeah we have my kid it was
a kid ate when kadai came out was about
probably about two thousand one yep
my accountant wet radiohead's accountant
at the time that I got a [ __ ] so dozen
dollars and virtually impossible to get
yeah I tried to get tickets oh yeah the
three times that I've known them to be
in Los Angeles all three times I try to
get tickets could not get them or they
were way out of my you know the size
range Shack yeah and and then I the
closest I got was sneaking into the
woods I'd never seen them and it was
borderline a religious experience
everybody says that [ __ ] first of all
this was kid a hadn't even been out that
long it was kiddi was so good and but
they were still doing like a lot of ok
computer song off blood they played
everything I wanted to hear that a lot
about the back of my head and been like
this is it I've like word I'm good uh it
was so fun good it was cool it like it
was me my manager stew so vulgar recipes
my accountant and is it my managers
assistant your account juice oval
there's another but like that the
instant the concert started it was like
I was there by myself oh yeah I got
doing great things wouldn't have been
more excited to see anything in my
entire life a good show feels that way
where you're like nothing else is here
but me yeah you guys dude it was the
best [ __ ] it was a bit i haven't seen
and I've seen Radiohead two more times
since then we're out the bowl all three
times worth no one the first I was Greek
oh sorry sorry Greek and the two of them
to agree had to be amazing agree was
mine and I hear they're like light show
is incredible there dude James was oh so
good my I mean I wanted to it was like I
like this is it is a duty covers because
I hear they always do like really cool
covers no that'll back then they weren't
doing that it was all ok computer k day
in a few the benz advanced stuff it dude
it was so [ __ ] good I think about it
all the time I saw them twice but it
they're not in my top top two not this
is a top too but just to best favor
concerts they're not even in there cuz I
saw him two times at festivals so
outside lands which that the setup was
not great and finger on the layout yet
it could be a little like an in the
sound they can I will sell you know
festivals sometimes you know you kind of
water down the the whole experience
because they have to sacrifice for
everybody else on the festival their own
you know kind of thing they were there
lot slightly different set lists and
then there live the visuals are aren't
the same as they would be watch them on
the run and they're playing shorter sets
to have the lights theory to the second
time was a coachella both hubs are
awesome and I was like [ __ ] finally I
get to see Radiohead but they didn't
make the top my top favorite concert
anyway we got Butcher was low 20 years
uh um you were the third is one of mine
was also at the Greek the grease get a
lot of mentions things uh my third it
might I by third one if we were to go
three would be a Greek one really I saw
so monsters of Falk was this band it was
like a supergroup so it was uh conor
oberst bright eyes jim james from my
morning jacket blue bands you already
super love ya uh em ward and then um i
came to the fourth cousin but he works
with bright eyes is a he plays guitar so
in monsters of folk so the for them get
together and they release they write and
record this album uh and they're all you
know alt-country whatever so they call
themselves of monsters of folk and they
write an entire album of original songs
and it's [ __ ] awesome and i listened
to it so much and then they were like oh
we're going on tour it's a one-and-only
tour they did it's the one only album
they did they haven't done anything
since together so they're playing at the
Greek and I'm like I gotta [ __ ] go so
me and my best friend Robert were like
we got to do this [ __ ] did and we go and
the entire had great seats to somehow we
just got seats and they happen to be
like 11 rows back river right there so
it was like a warm summer [ __ ] night
perfect night to go to the greek and
these guys all come out and the concert
was so [ __ ] interesting because they
played all the songs from that
album but in between like every second
song they would play songs from their
own respective band at school so and and
they would plan like together or like if
they play each other's I think there was
a couple cases of that so you'd get like
bright eyes and Jim James singing a my
morning jacket's on together and you're
like I can't believe like your favorite
songs so you essentially got to see like
four bands in one night laying all this
super awesome [ __ ] mellow alt-country
stuff like they rocked out a little bit
to that album that monsters of folk
album is fantastic that's the kinda you
wish there was video of read like watch
all the time there might be or like if
it was a concert film yeah wow that's
how a culture familiar be so cool but I
don't know man this the divide that
night and like the songs that they
played and it was it just felt like it
went on for like three hours but in a
good way yet the kind of thing good that
you know only like really good musicians
yeah and and it just like I don't know
that it just hit me perfectly and I was
like halfway through I was just like
this is one of the best concerts i've
ever been to yeah and it wasn't anything
like there wasn't a crazy light show
there were fireworks they did rock out
crazy hard break instruments there
wasn't like anything crazy but it was
just the way it was put together was so
like careful and thought out and the
covers of each other songs with a
[ __ ] awesome touch that's cool yeah
it was just so so good and I've been
wanting to put out a second album sensin
like they haven't that's why a hard
thing to to facilitate with everybody's
schedules everybody's busy like it let's
do another album side project album with
you they talk to conor oberst about it
and he was just like it's just hard he's
like we've talked about it and we want
to but it's like we don't wanna rush it
a and B we've just had a hard time like
organizing all our schedules gap because
they're all in like really successful
yeah that's what I mean they're gonna be
hard to putting out albums hey let's all
take eight months off from our busy
schedules and you know yeah the entire
album yeah yeah but dude I mean I still
think about that show every time the
Greek comes up that's one of
I've seen so many goddamn concert at the
Greek but that is always like when I
think Greek Theatre that's the number
one show her yeah that's a great that's
a great great venue and i like that i
like the Ford minutes because it's even
a smaller version yeah like you know
those like Russian egg things new open I
wonder i'd like the hollywood bowl in
the Greek and the Ford yeah you know the
creek is great that's outdoors but it's
not as much of a situation to go to as
the Hollywood Bowl yeah because I balls
right my wall up to all this year yeah I
camera the last time I drove to the
greek yeah i just get walk out my door
and then take you know whatever 10
minute walk up the hill yeah i would i
would walk to the [ __ ] in a ball oh yeah
i wouldn't [ __ ] you know you can I've
seen parking at the Hollywood Bowl forty
dollars I've had tickets for concerts
there were twenty eight dollars and then
you pay what you are paying double to
pass time I went to the i went to the
bowl last year and it was definitely
twenty dollars to park at that place
there's like an empty lot across from
starbucks oh yeah okay yeah and then
that wasn't that bad the trick with the
ball for anyone who lives in LA uh is
you park at the Hollywood Highland
complex and then you get validated any
one of the stores it's two bucks for
like four hours and then you walk up to
the ball if you want to drive nowadays
it's just [ __ ] take an uber and have
it drop you off five blocks away yeah
have a drop you off at hollywood
highland yeah yeah and then you just
walk up highland yeah yeah like 15
minute walk yeah i'm not one of my best
ones i would be shocked if it's not your
second one uh-huh because well as now
we've been to a lot of concerts together
yes but we've also been to you know you
hear your buddy talking about a constant
you like oh i was at that concert to
right and that's this one which was at
the Forum Prince when Stevie Wonder his
studio on his birthday all right right
and Princeton was doing like he did I
think was 21 21 shows a $21 all the
twenty one night stand so 21 nights he
would every ticket was 21 bucks so
Thursday they will go on sale and you
would buy your ticket and it was just a
crapshoot where it was uh-huh you know
sometimes you would be right on the
floor sometimes you
up in the top is just total crapshoot
yeah and every venue was like he did the
Troubadour one night for him another
night it was so [ __ ] rain in the
forum a shitload of times yeah it was
almost like are you know like a
three-month residency there a lot of the
money was going to save the forum and
renovate it and even back then they were
getting money together for that yeah
that was the first thing that they was
the first push to do that was what what
year was that concert [ __ ] man that's
probably five five six years ago yeah
and he would always you know he would do
three three-and-a-half for our sets I am
not joking now at four times of the 21 I
went to four of them yeah and the best
one which human dollars with the best
one yet stay there you go as in fact
that's the Jew account Ninian goes to
concerts with those guys the number to
Kurt the bean counter over here that's
why $84 of it there yeah does know that
for service if anybody doesn't have an
abacus on them after service fees it is
708 yeah eight hundred and twenty four
dollars and uh so you know these things
and he's like you guys ready to party
all night there would be like yeah and
he's like we'll see about that and
people would leave after two and a half
hours not knowing there's three more
encores and then he would do an encore
of you know 35 minutes and then people
would leave yeah and then he would come
and he would never stop coming out and
he kept changed to change outfits a
bunch of times and he would come back
but every time he would leave you would
just get closer and then everybody would
leave and then you will get closer again
and there's people that were around me
around my [ __ ] trust me don't leave he
is absolutely coming back out yeah you
know and he always would come back out
and on the one that I love so much and
they're all great I mean and they were
all different you know he would do I
mean he has he would play 12 instruments
president it's Prince Prince and um
Chris Maddock and funny and you know
remember what about the medley part oh
yeah where that yeah he goes he was
playing like he cuz he has you know just
a billion songs so we did a medley of
like you know some of his hits and stuff
and then like after three songs in you
know are like three up three songs in
the of the medley he stops he's on piano
and he stops and he goes I got so many
hits and he sits back down and then hit
a little red Corvette after that yeah it
was so [ __ ] funny and he would do
[ __ ] like where you like uh his asst
India's has that deep ass voice when he
talks man here's a song I wrote about
myself when I was looking at myself in
the mirror and then it'd be sexy
[ __ ] disha like that Prince but
he was like you talk about saving the
forum and you always go you know I saw
you know the Stevie Wonder here I saw
the Jackson 5 here I saw the Eagles here
I saw and he would list all the bands
that he had seen at the forum when he
was living in Los Angeles and he's like
actually right now Stevie Wonder's
birthday so if we sing loud enough maybe
he can hear that everybody sing happy
birthday to him and then right out of
the ground come Stevie Wonder on a grand
piano and a bunch of songs together and
you're like holy Sh I mean that's pretty
much going to yeah I'm talking to icons
I missed the first 10 seconds of the
stevie wonder song because I was rolling
my tongue back yeah I wouldn't put ya
eyeballs back into a bunch of songs
together than they play together for a
while and then select so called a week
later you know I see naked like the
improper commerce tourism like that in a
sec dude you won't plea and I'm like I
was there and we just hugged we just hug
for a long time to legends that's the
thing where you're like yeah saw prince
was the wonder you're like sorry what
back up and it's two legends that are
great live there actual musicians are
not lip-syncing they're not [ __ ]
shitty they're not like [ __ ] you and
collecting your money and I'm out of
here it was saying like our real real
real musicians that care about being in
that exact moment and to be able to see
ya that's absolutely a question my
number one does my number 14 number one
concert ever yeah probably we're like it
you could see if I could see it again I
would not want I would not change a
thing I would absolutely uh that's a
good way to determine like which one if
you had to pick one to see again what
would it be mine would still you know
kid a kid a tour that would be me I
would see that again without question
see I didn't really pick mine in like in
terms of my favorites ever but that's a
good way to put it but that day yeah
that changes yeah what it would be I
guess I mean mine would have to be like
the first time I saw tool the first time
you see a band you worship yeah that's
the thing it was the first time I'd seen
Radiohead and it was like yeah to me one
of their peak moments where they were
just so good and and I was it just in
like a fever pitch of worshiping them
that's my second it was just like I
could [ __ ] faint right now this may
get too real for me right like he
sounded great the merch was great it was
like he was well yeah and almeda work
there's all those special editions like
it was just a perf I was the perfect age
they with the whole thing was just dead
on yes oh my honorable mentions like
muse at the at the agent when I saw muse
at The Wiltern after what is that it
would give me a name absolution
absolution that album when that album
came out which is like second or third
album yeah I saw them at the wiltern and
I've never been so blown away by three
people before him alive yeah their live
shows her that was my honorable mention
elton john and billy joel honorable
mention where was that I saw them at the
now-defunct Hoosier dome which is now
the Lucas Oil Stadium or whatever in
Indian my catch your name uh yeah yeah
absolutely but that was like half the is
like two grand pianos facing each other
half was all-american half was all
British like huge flag and you know the
pianos with that and they would both
come out and they did one song together
and then Elton John did like 90 minutes
wow I mean Billy Joel came out and they
bolted another song together and then
Billy Joel did 90 minutes and then they
both came out and did piano man at the
end Oh the only reason it wasn't in my
top two was because it was like 90,000
people and most of them were like 50
year old yuppies right and I was 24 all
right had I seen something like that
like a smaller venue and you know I mean
it was just too
who had such a corporate vibe to me you
know and my seats were like pretty far
away that I was coming yeah this is cool
but it seemed like I was listening to
like classic rock yeah you know I mean
it's like a Stones concert wait I mean
both of them were great i really came
away like super impressed ability also
my honorable mention to me and one thing
and I think I've I know I think I've
told you this but I don't know if it's
with you this you know how you say it
like you can listen to one concert yeah
again and just see it like it was a
Gallagher was at the comedy store mm-hmm
and this is like when he first I had
never met him before he comes around and
then we took him out back and got him
stoned and then we're sitting at the
front patio and he's the rolling stones
are playing and he's kind of like stone
and kind of Mike and I'm in my head I'm
like this guy is such a [ __ ] hippie
stoner guy and he's in his 70s I bet
he's seen some [ __ ] great concerts in
his life so I say to him I'm like a man
if you could go back and relive one
concert you know the same question yeah
what would it be and he thinks for a
second he goes Led Zeppelin 1969 in
Atlanta and that's exactly what I said
I'm like holy [ __ ] man this guy's called
Led Zeppelin in 69 that's sane and I go
who the [ __ ] opened up for that show and
it goes a shitload of acid brother like
that might be the funniest thing you've
ever said yeah never made me laugh in
your entire life including when I was 10
yeah you're smashing [ __ ] fruit and
that's the [ __ ] coolest thing you
could have ever said that's grimy court
mcallen to has been on the podcast
before he has seen a ton of great shows
when he was young he seen Zeppelin he's
seen the stones back in the head they
can't talk to him about live concerts
he's seen I can't imagine buddy him and
david alan grier work like going
head-to-head in our greenroom once about
concerts they've seen and it was like
whoa whoa it's like yeah Earth Wind and
Fire Everly Brothers open up your like
what
well that's why I that's why I [ __ ]
go to every concert I can or when I was
like in my twenties I was going to ever
cuz I was like I want to see all the
[ __ ] I don't want to be older and be
like I missed those guys I miss those
guys another good honorable mention for
me was um in like 88 I saw a Chicago at
Grant Park in Chicago during taste of
chicago haha and they like what the
horns I mean they were like full blown
like I didn't like it's one of those
were you like Indian I was in high
school so it was like really really even
a cooler thing because you're like you
know 16 or whether [ __ ] and I'm like
watching and I'm like I know every
single song they're playing and I didn't
know they were off in the same band wow
I didn't like 12 songs in a row you're
like these are all from the same band
holy [ __ ] I did not know that no my
second one did you do too uh ya know oh
yeah strokes and radio strokes Radiohead
yeah so my second one is a bad one that
turned into a great one oh that's good
like that so and another thing i was
thinking too is like i think i have a
hard time putting like bands like that i
really love into like all time favorite
concerts because the bands i love i've
seen so many times that the first one
isn't like if you only saw ban you left
once we think about it all time but like
you know wilco tool TV on the radio more
times I've seen on them so many times
it's hard for me to go like this one
time yeah we're like all that was amazed
i'll blend in kinda so this was a TV on
the radio concert and I this was this
year so I'd seen twice already in 2015
they played at the fonda and I was like
okay cool great and they've a venue yeah
they played at the palladium which is
literally you know few minutes away a
few months later oh yeah I'm of course
I'm going again I love TV on the radio
so I go and for some reason they I
bought a bottle of water and it was six
dollars and not [ __ ] ruined didn't
ruin the show but it really made me
[ __ ] pissed right so they were great
the ban was great but I couldn't get the
[ __ ] water thing out of my head right
so I felt about my 18 dollar beer yeah
so but every time I think about the
concert like for you know for the few
is a I was thinking about that and I was
like [ __ ] that right so I end up writing
this article for a magazine about that
bottle of water incident but I turned
into like live nation and ticketmaster
are [ __ ] people out of the live
concert going experience right this
whole [ __ ] thing I love it so I wrote
it and then paste magazine published it
so and it ended with this whole thing I
was like you know hopefully someone
somewhere any of these places can like
you know remember what it was like to go
to a concert and have fun and not feel
ripped off from like the moment you
purchase a ticket tool you know the
moment you leave you know but I was like
no one's gonna read it no one's gonna
give a [ __ ] or whatever you know and
then I get an email from the magazine
hey your article went live this morning
I was like cool thanks and I kind of
just looked in real fast see like what
they edited you know all that stuff
fifteen minutes later I got an email
from the president of live nation and I
was like oh yeah I was like this can't
be real right and I look at the [ __ ]
I was like it's real he's like we need
to talk he's like hello Nick Youssef
wearing a blue shirt right red chair
drinking a coffee i'm watching you right
now and he goes we need to talk and I'm
like oh that's all it said yeah retro
thing we need to talk Wow and I was like
[ __ ] oh yeah what the [ __ ] is gonna have
of president of music I love the guy
that will control anything you can ever
probably see again you're banned from
all concerts you know so I hit him back
I'm like I'd love to and he goes I'm out
of town I get back in a few days let's
talk call call call this number will
talk so one thing leads to another we I
get on the phone them talk to him for
over an hour about edges all this stuff
I mean I can't say what but if I can you
not say what because I just it is an
offer the record thing okay yeah respect
that yeah so but it was a great
conversation good dude uh and then that
led to UM
of the greatest concerts I've ever seen
which was recently and i know will be
it'll stay as one of the best concerts
ever seen because it was a bucket list
artist and I've just been dynasian
forever so I know de Leon at the forum
right yeah now you got you got tickets
for that through this conversation yeah
from that awful experience at the
palladium and then deciding to be vocal
about it now you know I've see if it was
now let me ask you this again you know
there's some confidentiality here you
can say too much was the was the crux
this conversation um how can I what you
go to a lot of concerts you're a big fan
of music like what can we do as live
nation to make this experience better it
was like all it was all that stuff it
was everything that I talked about in
that article just like it was a
conversation about all that okay um but
it kind of was like I mean we found like
common ground and stuff and he's like a
good dude you know and then I was like I
want to go see Laura and the next thing
you know and I want to free waters right
right um but yeah the next thing you
know I'm front row at on the floor
watching Neil yah three hours of just
[ __ ] hits rare tracks all this stuff
is really [ __ ] is really insane yeah
my second one was um uh and a little bit
of it is the company you keep Jason
galloran and I yeah when um and I really
feel like it was there and i still love
this band are always on the span but i
feel like it was really their last last
push of the whole band being together
was when black crowes did four nights
five nights in a row at the fonda yeah
and then they went to San Francisco and
recorded a live album I mean a live you
know concert film which was great we
five nights in row we went we went to
three of the five and and literally
watched them for two and a half three
hours like rehearse their that's all
live concert and each night you know
sets were a little different and and
literally we were just like there's the
stage right you know it's like as you
know ten feet away yeah we're just
watching night and day and it you know
they the band had broken up so many
times and they're all completely back
together and for a rare probably 50 days
everybody seemed sober and we're able to
rock and not fight and not be smack down
here was awesome dude they just wrecked
it and then the next thing we're like
dude let's [ __ ] go again and then
dude we don't have tickets we don't
[ __ ] need like it in in Jason line is
the king of just showing it I'm like
dude we don't have ticks did your good
we're fine well [ __ ] get in yeah
you're any talks to a door guy for
[ __ ] five minutes and the next thing
you know we're in again I don't know how
he does that it has a magical touch with
with us being able to do that yeah
that's insane and that absolutely and
that was like kind of like how but what
you were saying every like sometimes
it's like seeing a band that you worship
for the print and that wasn't the that
was probably the tenth time I'd seen six
maybe six by six seven eight eight time
yeah that I had seen black cross but
there was just something about that one
I hadn't seen him in like six years I
didn't think they were going to get back
together and if they did it was going to
be some hodgepodge version of them it
wasn't like wasn't you know the original
guitar player it wasn't [ __ ] original
drum is always somebody was gone but it
was just all of them and they just
[ __ ] totally killed it and as one
that I'll just never ever I just won't
ever forget it and absolutely would go
back to that one again if I could yeah
yeah that's [ __ ] great you wanna go
see more shows I just thinking that I
was like I want to go see a [ __ ]
concert I've been to one in a while yeah
I don't think well I guess I've lot that
week I went to Neil Young I went to
three concerts that we can you go to a
lot of shows lately that's just like
that week I was like there they all kind
of there's just a bunch of [ __ ] in
October and all landed and writers
gating letter to the president effect
live nation uh it was Neil Young the war
on drugs at the Greek and then Eagles of
Death Metal when they played the
the Tower Records documentary really
sorry who's who um yeah that was three
in one [ __ ] week and I was like Jamie
to so many goddamn shows and it it had
been maybe a little bit before and I
haven't really been in one sense but
yeah now I want I want to go see see
something [ __ ] cool oh by the way for
any tool fans out there which there
should be some or more they announced
the first nine live dates of 2016 the
other alone yeah so the tickets go on
sale friday so they're playing they're
nine dates with like scattered all over
the country for some reason and then
probably fill them in when they announce
the rest but closest one to San Diego
geez really close oh yeah I'm going
isn't it yeah imagine that uh to the guy
in a tool shirt sitting across from us
that's right yeah I've so many of these
shirts now um I'm like buying my you
that I did was able to afford them like
I wanted that shirt oh 16 that one when
I was [ __ ] 15 uh yeah everybody go
see a lot go see a concert fine to be
and you like you know it's fun to go
find a local find a venue that is like
respectable like a legitimate good one
and then just pick a night where they
just have some you know two or three
pack a showcase night or a couple bands
you haven't heard of and tickets or what
58 bucks and just go to that yep cuz
that band in five years could be like a
big deal and you can go [ __ ] I saw
them it was me and 14 people at
spaceland or satellite or whatever they
call it no one [ __ ] knew they were
tickets for seven bucks that's a story
you'll tell in 10 12 years that's how I
got turned on to wilco that's how I
turned on the trail of dead yeah
somebody else's like to come check this
[ __ ] band out there [ __ ] great I
got a cool following and is like before
they totally you know and then when they
blow up you're like cool man i'm [ __ ]
sand them way back when just go see live
music man it's good for your soul you
have to go yeah what time is it oh yeah
ok we could I mean we could just do this
for another [ __ ] our like this
concert in it that way it's every time I
do this podcast which by the way I have
I now passed Jerry I was thinking that
earlier today I was like are tied
hey [ __ ] you kid and that could I have a
half a one I have a half a one yeah I
had that one I did with Stuart remember
oh yeah so this is three and a half I
think you're rockin superstar Jones with
his fancy air jordan this is only a hip
it done it three times oh and Jerry's
gonna like the second this goes up guys
just seething we're gonna get a text
like I gotta be on next week uh-huh yeah
we'll figure out her Kevin we were both
on and he nice arm wrestle the whole
time arm wrestling that would be funny I
got a half a one up on you Jerry yeah
that would be fun it's true uh well
thanks again for doing this deal of both
you always fun to have you know about
follow teeb on uh on the twitter at the
tube uh your Instagram is Jason Tebow
yeah i spelled near-impossible the other
jason spelled differently tebow has
never been spelled correctly by anyone
ever not even my parents j ayso nth iba
ult yep right they did that right off a
memory yep those grab and then listen to
punch drunk sports that's on the all
things comedy network uh and there you
have it man thanks again dude do i love
you guys i'll do this anytime brother
Jim